en vídeos previos hemos hablado de la
ley de demanda que se refiere a algo que
seguramente nos parece intuitivo se
refiere a que si algún bien tiene un
precio alto la cantidad demandada de
dicho bien será muy poca y a medida que
el precio disminuya la cantidad
demandada aumentará al graficar una
curva de demanda como la que vemos aquí
en donde el precio está en el eje
vertical y la cantidad está en el eje
horizontal la cual es la convención
estándar para la mayoría de los
economistas
tendremos una curva con pendiente
negativa en este vídeo vamos a analizar
el por qué esta curva tiene una
pendiente negativa aunque es probable
que para muchos de ustedes esto sea sólo
un poco de sentido común si el precio
disminuye entonces yo voy a querer
comprar más de ese bien y todos los
demás querrán hacer lo mismo pero vamos
a analizar un poco más a fondo la razón
de por qué queremos más de algún bien
cuando el precio disminuye una de las
categorías de las posibles razones por
las que queremos más de algo cuando el
precio disminuye es lo que los
economistas llaman efecto sustitución
esta es la idea de que por ejemplo si
tenemos el precio en relación con la
cantidad
y al inicio el precio de los dulces está
por aquí digamos que a 40 pesos la
cantidad demandada en el mercado es de
100 unidades de dulces si por alguna
razón el precio disminuye a 20 pesos es
posible que muchas personas se
encuentren atractivos esos dulces con
respecto a otras cosas que podrían
comprar por ejemplo alguien está
considerando si compra frutas o si
compra dulces que al principio costaban
lo mismo 40 pesos las 100 unidades de
fruta o de dulces pero ahora el precio
de los dulces disminuye a 20 pesos por
unidad y ahora los dulces son más
atractivos que la fruta así que la
cantidad de fruta que hubiera sido
comprada cuando los dulces costaban lo
mismo es ahora sustituida por los dulces
porque son un mejor trato voy a
sustituir la fruta por los dulces esta
es una de las razones por las que
tenemos una mayor cantidad demandada de
dulces imaginemos que ahora la cantidad
demandada es de 250 unidades otra gran
categoría del porque esperamos que la
curva de demanda tenga una pendiente
negativa cuando nos referimos a bienes
normales
los vídeos hablaremos de los bienes
inferiores es el efecto ingreso de
cierta forma esta es la categoría más
intuitiva cuando el precio pasa de 40
pesos a 20 pesos el costo de esos 100
dulces disminuye a la mitad por lo que
los consumidores tendrán 20 pesos extra
para comprar más dulces o para comprar
otras cosas la última categoría que usan
los economistas para explicar el por qué
la curva de demanda tiene pendiente
negativa y que ya hemos mencionado en
vídeos anteriores es la idea de que
disminuye la utilidad marginal es decir
que las primeras cantidades de dulces
que se encuentran en el mercado son muy
valiosas para los consumidores quizá
algunos son adictos a los dulces y sus
cuerpos tienen dependencia a ellos pero
en cuanto a estas personas quedan
satisfechas las siguientes cantidades
adicionales o esa cantidad marginal
tendrá una utilidad un poco menor así
que conforme tenemos más y más dulces la
utilidad marginal disminuye cada vez más
esta es otra razón del por qué la curva
de demanda tiene una pendiente negativa
con eso terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo